Que ce soit les chatbox, les logiciels
de traduction automatique
ou encore les enceintes connectées,
de plus en plus d'applications semblent
être capables de comprendre notre langue.
Jusqu'à une période récente, quand on voulait
s'adresser à un ordinateur,
le seul moyen était d'utiliser un
"langage de programmation",
un truc artificiel, très formalisé,
avec des règles précises.
Mais de plus en plus il semblerait que grâce
aux méthodes d'intelligence artificielle,
les machines soient capables de comprendre
ce qu'on appelle le "langage naturel".
C'est-à-dire les langues que les humains
utilisent au quotidien,
comme le français ou l'anglais.
Est-ce qu'on peut dire que les IA comprennent
vraiment ce qu'on leur raconte,
qu'elles sont capables de penser
avec les mêmes mots que nous?
Eh bien, pour s'en faire une idée on va
se pencher sur les méthodes utilisées
par ces algorithmes pour manipuler
le langage naturel.
[Jingle]
Dans cette vidéo on va essentiellement
parler des techniques d'IA
qu'on regroupe sous le terme de
"machine learning",
l'apprentissage automatique,
et plus spécifiquement des fameuses
techniques de "deep learning",
l'apprentissage profond.
Pour ceux que ça intéresse, j'avais déjà fait
un épisode sur le sujet,
mais je vais quand même rappeler
les principes de base.
L'idée est de considérer un algorithme
qui est en gros une fonction,
c'est-à-dire comme une machine mathématique
à qui on donne une entrée X
et qui va produire une certaine sortie Y.
Et on va apprendre à cet algorithme
à faire quelque chose qui nous intéresse.
Prenons un cas concret classique:
imaginons qu'on veuille
qu'un algorithme soit capable de reconnaitre
ce qu'il y a sur des images.
En entrée X on veut pouvoir
lui donner des images
et en sortie Y on attend pour chaque image,
un mot qui la décrit.
Par exemple ici, on veut que l'algorithme
nous réponde: "Chat".
Pour en arriver là,
ça se passe en deux temps,
au départ l'algorithme n'est pas entrainé,
il répond donc n'importe quoi,
donc dans la première phase,
la phase d'apprentissage,
on va lui montrer des exemples de
ce qu'on voudrait qu'il fasse,
par exemple en lui filant
une base de données
de milliers d'images auxquelles
on a déjà associé les bons mots.
Et, en voyant ces exemples, l'algorithme
va se modifier progressivement
pour s'adapter à ce qu'on lui demande
de faire.
Dit comme ça, ça a l'air magique,
un algorithme qui se modifie,
mais mathématiquement ça se formalise bien.
La fonction mathématique qui relie Y et X
dans l'algorithme
dispose d'une très grande quantité
de paramètres,
on les appelle des poids et on note ça
généralement "W".
Et voyez ces paramètres comme des boutons
que l'algorithme peut tourner
pour faire varier la façon dont Y
est construit à partir de X.
Durant la phase d'apprentissage, ces poids
sont ajustés
de manière à coller aux exemples
de la base de données,
ça peut prendre un certain temps
en fonction de la taille de la base,
du nombre de poids et de la complexité
du problème.
Et une fois cette phase terminée,
l'algorithme est prêt,
il est entraîné et on peut s'en servir,
c'est la phase d'utilisation.
On lui présente de nouvelles images,
qu'il n'a jamais vues et,
si tout fonctionne bien, il sera capable
de reconnaître ce qu'il y a dessus.
Voilà pour les grands principe
du machine learning.
Là, je vous ai présenté le truc d'une façon
assez abstraite,
je ne vous ai pas vraiment expliqué
ce qu'on va utiliser
comme fonction pour réaliser tout ce travail.
Ces derniers temps on utilise majoritairement
les réseaux de neurones
et notamment les réseaux dits "profonds"
qui ont l'avantage d'être à la fois
très puissants et très flexibles,
mais la structure, l'architecture précise
de ces réseaux
doit souvent être adaptée au problème
qu'on considère.
Dans le cas de la reconnaissance d'image
on utilise
ce qu'on appelle des réseaux de convolution
qui ont une capacité à reconnaître
des choses intéressantes
dans une image en l'analysant successivement
à différentes échelles,
d'une façon hiérarchique.
Par exemple sur cette image, un réseau
de convolution va détecter d'abord
les variations de luminosité
d'un pixel à l'autre,
qui représentent une frontière
ou un trait
puis ces informations seront assemblées
pour reconnaître
des bouts de segments ou des morceaux
de courbes,
puis au niveau au dessus en combinant
les segments et les courbes,
il peut reconnaître des formes géométriques.
Et c'est en combinant à nouveau
ces caractéristiques globales
que le réseau peut finalement apprendre
à reconnaître des images complètes.
Alors évidemment je vous le décris de façon
assez sommaire,
mais on peut imaginer que cette façon
hiérarchique d'analyser
aux différentes échelles ressemble à la façon
dont notre vision à nous fonctionne.
Il y a quand même un point important
que j'ai passé sous silence:
ces algorithmes de réseaux de neurones,
je vous l'ai dit, n'ont rien de magique,
ce sont des fonctions mathématiques,
on les construit à partir d'opérations
simples comme l'addition,
la multiplication la fonction
exponentielle, etc.
Ça signifie que la seule chose que ces
réseaux peuvent manipuler
eh bien ce sont des nombres.
Alors là je vous ai dit que pour faire
de la reconnaissance d'image
on prenait des images en entrée et on avait
des mots en sortie, alors, comment on fait?
Pour les images c'est assez simple,
on prend les pixels,
on regarde leur luminosité ou bien
leurs couleurs
en rouge/vert/bleu et ça nous donne
des nombres.
Pour une image de 400 par 400 pixels
en couleur,
ça fait pas loin de 500 000 nombres
en entrée,
c'est beaucoup, mais au moins ce sont
des nombres que le réseau peut manipuler.
Et pour la sortie?
Eh bien notre réseau ne parle ni anglais
ni français,
il ne sait pas écrire des mots comme
"chat" ou "voiture".
Donc il faut lui cadrer les choses,
pour faire ça on va se fixer à l'avance
une liste de mots possibles
par exemple 1 000 mots très courants
qui décrivent des objets, des lieux,
des animaux
chacun de ces mots reçoit un numéro
de 1 à 1 000,
par exemple sa position alphabétique
dans la liste et quand on présente
la base de données d'exemple à l'algorithme,
on utilise ces numéros.
Une fois le réseau entraîné, chaque fois
qu'on lui présentera une image,
il nous donnera un numéro entre 1 et 1 000
correspondant à ce qu'il pense
avoir reconnu sur l'image.
Et même, généralement les algorithmes
font un peu mieux que ça,
en sortie ils vont plutôt sortir une longue
liste de de 1 000 nombre entre 0 et 1
qui correspondent à la probabilité estimée
de chacun des 1 000 mots,
par exemple sur cette image la réponse
sera peut-être "chat" à 97%
"chien" à 2% et canard à 1%
et puis tout le reste "voiture, avion,
chaise, etc." presque à 0%
Petit point vocabulaire: cette longue liste
de nombre en sortie,
on va appeler ça un "vecteur", je vais
plusieurs fois utiliser ce terme
et ça désignera à chaque fois juste
une grosse liste de nombre réels.
Ça doit vous sembler bizarre car ça semble
assez loin des vecteurs
représentés par des petites flèches
qu'on utilise pour faire de la géométrie,
mais il y a un lien.
En géométrie si vous avez un quadrillage,
vous pouvez représenter un vecteur
par ses coordonnées, il vous en faudra deux,
pour un vecteur du plan c'est une liste
de deux nombres réels,
en trois dimensions il vous en faudra trois.
Eh bien on va juste étendre le principe
en disant
que n'importe quelle liste de nombre,
même s'il y en a 1000, c'est un vecteur,
un vecteur dans un espace à 1000 dimensions.
Oui, ça a l'air un peu vertigineux comme ça,
mais vous allez voir, ça va bien se passer.
Bien, tout ce que je vous ai décrit là,
ça fonctionne très bien pour des images,
les capacités de reconnaissance
des algorithmes sont aujourd'hui
au même niveau que celles des humains,
mais pour reconnaître et comprendre
des phrases en langage naturel,
eh bien ça va être plus compliqué.
Quand on entraine un algorithme
à reconnaître des images,
on doit choisir une taille fixe,
par exemple 400 pixels par 400 pixels,
si on a une image de taille différente,
on peut toujours la mettre à l'échelle
ou bien tailler dedans.
Le problème des phrases c'est qu'elles ont
des tailles très variables
et qu'on ne peut pas faire
ce genre de choses,
si on entraîne un algorithme pour une taille
fixe, disons des phrases de 10 mots,
on ne peut pas compresser ou découper
les phrases plus longues
en plusieurs morceaux sans risquer
d'en perdre le sens.
Et puis dans une phrase, l'ordre joue
un rôle essentiel,
ce qui se passe à un bout de la phrase
peut complètement modifier
le sens de ce qu'il y avait au début.
Ça se voit bien dans un des premiers
problèmes auxquels on s'attaque
quand on essaie de manipuler
du langage naturel,
ce qu'on appelle parfois la classification
des sentiments, ou des opinions.
Imaginez que vous lisiez un commentaire
sur internet
à propos d'un produit ou
d'une chaîne youtube tiens!
et qu'on vous demande de juger
automatiquement
si ce commentaire est positif,
négatif ou neutre.
Eh bien on peut voir ça comme un problème
de machine learning
En entrée on file un texte et, en sortie,
on veut des probabilités estimées
que le texte soit positif, négatif,
neutre etc.
À première vue ça ne paraît pas
très compliqué,
on peut se faire une bonne idée
de la tonalité d'un commentaire,
juste avec la présence de mots clés
du genre "mauvais",
mais à y regarder de plus prés,
c'est pas si simple,
il peut y avoir des formulations comme:
Hé, il y a le mot "mauvais", mais
c'est un commentaire plutôt positif,
donc la séquence entière des mots
est très importante pour saisir le sens.
La classification automatique des sentiments
n'est qu'un exemple de problème
qu'on peut essayer de résoudre
par des algorithmes de traitement
du langage naturel
Mais il y en a plein d'autres,
il y a la traduction automatique bien sûr,
où on essaie de prendre une phrase en entrée
dans une langue
et d'avoir en sortie la même phrase
dans une autre langue.
Il y a le résumé de texte, où on donne
un long texte en entrée
et on veut récupérer en sortie un résumé en,
disons quelques phrases seulement.
Il y a aussi la génération de texte
où on veut cette fois un algorithme
qui soit capable de prolonger un texte
qu'on a commencé écrire.
Tous ces problèmes appartiennent
à cette discipline qu'on appelle
le traitement du langage naturel,
on utilise souvent l'abréviation
NLP en anglais pour:
Natural Language Processing.
[Jingle]
Pour commencer, comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure,
les algorithmes qu'on utilise ne savent
pas manipuler des mots en tant que tels,
ils ne manipulent que des nombres.
Dans le cas de la reconnaissance d'image
on se fixe un certain nombre de mot,
typiquement 1 000, on les numérote et
on choisit de ne faire qu'avec ceux-ci.
Ça veut dire que dans la liste de mots
on aura certainement le mot "piano"
qui est courant, mais pas forcément
le mot "clavecin"
et donc, si une image représente un clavecin
eh bien elle sera certainement classée
comme étant un piano, mais c'est pas
forcément très grave.
Mais pour faire de la traduction par exemple,
on ne peut pas faire ça
et se limiter à seulement 1 000 mots courants,
si dans la phrase à traduire il y a le mot
"clavecin"
l'algorithme de traduction ne peut pas dire:
"ben ce mot-là je ne le connais pas
donc je traduis pas".
Alors là, vous allez me dire "facile hein,
au lieu de prendre une liste de 1 000 mots,
on n'a qu'à prendre un dictionnaire complet,
avec disons les 50 000 mots les plus courants,
ça devrait le faire, on représente
chaque mot avec un nombre
entre 1 et 50 000 par exemple sa position
alphabétique dans le dictionnaire
et puis on est bon! "
Alors oui, mais ça pose deux problèmes,
déjà passer de 1 000 à 50 000
ça fait une bonne différence de taille
donc pour les algorithmes
ça complique pas mal la tâche,
et puis surtout
numéroter par exemple alphabétiquement
les mots ça complique les choses.
Si on fait comme on vient de dire,
le mot "piano" sera par exemple codé
avec le numéro 32 121 et clavecin
avec le numéro 4 164
et donc ils seront traités de manière
complètement différentes
comme deux concepts totalement indépendants,
or nous, on sait qu'il y a des similarités.
Si je vous dis:
"il plaqua un accord sur le clavecin"
vous comprenez le sens de la phrase
même si vous n'aviez jamais entendu
de votre vie
l'idée de plaquer un accord sur un clavecin,
mais vous l'avez probablement déjà entendue
en parlant d'un piano,
vous savez qu'un clavecin et un piano
partagent des similarités,
ce sont des instruments,
ils ont un clavier, etc.
Donc dans notre façon de comprendre
des phrases en langage naturel,
on exploite des similarités
ou des proximités de sens.
Si notre algorithme on lui file
juste 50 000 mots
comme des numéros sans relations, ben
il ne pourra pas faire ça,
il ne pourra pas utiliser ce qu'il sait
des pianos
pour l'appliquer aussi aux clavecins
si besoin.
Ce qu'il faudrait faire, c'est coder
les mots avec un principe
qui respecte leur sens et la façon
dont ils sont utilisés
Or, comme le disait le philosophe
Wittgenstein:
"la signification d'un mot c'est
son usage dans le langage".
Alors oui Monsieur Phi m'a dit que c'était
très chic de citer Wittgenstein.
Donc pour essayer d'attribuer à chaque mot
un nombre qui le représente bien,
eh bien il faut qu'on essaie de tenir compte
de son contexte d'utilisation.
Prenons un nouvel exemple: Le mot "Chat",
on a envie que le mot "Chien" soit
probablement représenté assez proche de lui,
ce sont deux animaux, des mammifères
quadrupèdes
et ce sont les deux animaux domestiques
les plus courants,
le chien et le chat sont donc
des concepts proches.
Alors là je vais avoir les teams
chien et chat
dans les commentaires, mais bon,
c'est pas grave.
Maintenant le mot "Lynx", on a probablement
envie qu'il soit aussi près du chat,
mais pas forcément si proche que ça du chien.
Alors, si on est dans un plan on aura envie
de le mettre ici par exemple
et vous voyez qu'on a besoin
d'une deuxième dimension.
Et ici, on aurait par exemple le loup,
le loup est au chien ce que
le lynx est au chat,
sa version sauvage plutôt que domestiquée.
Donc si on voulait attribuer des numéros
à ces quatre concepts,
on n'utiliserait pas un seul nombre,
mais plutôt deux pour chacun,
pour avoir les deux dimensions.
Le chat serait représenté
par le vecteur (1.1),
le chien (2.1), le lynx (1.2)
et le loup (2.2).
Alors là, ça marche bien parce que
j'ai juste quatre mots,
mais si j'en ai 50 000 c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué.
Pour que cette notion de proximité de sens
soit reflétée dans la proximité de vecteur,
les représenter dans un plan,
ça ne va pas suffire hein!
Je vais avoir besoin de beaucoup plus
de dimensions, disons… 300!
Et donc, à chaque mot on aimerait associer
non pas un ou deux nombres
mais un vecteur de 300 nombres
qui représenterait sa position
dans l'espace des significations,
avec une notion de proximité quand
deux mots semblent reliés.
Sur le papier, ça a l'air très bien,
mais en pratique ça semble
un travail titanesque d'identifier
les 300 dimensions
et de qualifier chacun des 50 000 mot.
Heureusement c'est un tâche qu'on peut
automatiser grâce à un réseau de neurones
On va utiliser un algorithme capable
de lire des millions de phrases
et d'identifier par lui-même les relations
de proximité
de façon à attribuer à chaque mot
du dictionnaire
un vecteur de coordonnées dans l'espace
de dimension 300.
Pour la langue anglaise, c'est ce que font
par exemple les algorithmes
"Word2vec" créé par Google, ou encore "Glove"
développé à l'université de Stanford.
J'ai récupéré les données de Glove,
elles sont en accès libre,
et j'ai regardé les vecteurs associés
aux mots
"chat, chien, loup et lynx" en anglais.
Pour chacun de ces mots on a une liste
de 300 nombres,
un vecteur de dimension 300 dans
l'espace des significations
Les nombres en eux-mêmes, ne veulent
strictement rien dire,
si vous me donnez un vecteur au hasard,
je ne peux pas franchement vous dire
ce que ça représente.
en revanche, avec ces vecteurs on peut
calculer une notion de proximité
et on voit que la similarité entre
"chien" et "chat" est de 80%,
celle entre "chat" et "lynx" de 42 %,
"chien" et "loup" 52%,
mais "chien" et "lynx" seulement 33%.
Alors que si on calcule la similarité
avec un mot qui n'a rien à voir,
genre le mot "processeur" eh bien
on ne trouve
que des valeurs de similarité très faibles.
D'après les données, la méthode semble
bien fonctionner
et grâce à tout cela on est donc capable
d'associer à chaque mot
un vecteur dans un certain espace
de significations.
Ces vecteurs sont des nombres, et on va donc
pouvoir les donner à des réseaux de neurones.
et si on en donne plusieurs à la suite,
on va leur donner: des phrases.
[jingle]
On l'a dit en intro, une des difficultés
avec la compréhension d'une phrase
par une machine, que ce soit pour
la traduire, la reformuler ou la compléter,
c'est que les phrases n'ont pas
de longueur fixe
contrairement à ce qu'on peut faire
en reconnaissance d'image
avec des images de taille donnée.
En principe on peut quand même essayer
d'utiliser le même type de réseau de neurones,
les réseaux de convolution, mais en pratique
ce n'est pas si efficace
et on a trouvé bien mieux et plus flexible:
les réseaux récurrents.
Pour comprendre le principe imaginez
une phrase, disons:
"Le chat mange goulûment la souris" .
Lisez cette phrase lentement, mot par mot.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans votre tête?
Eh bien, à chaque étape vous allez avoir
une compréhension incomplète de son sens,
mais qui se modifie,
se précise à chaque nouveau mot
que vous lisez.
"Le": OK, on ne sait pas grand chose.
"chat": ça va parler d'un chat,
mais on ne sait pas pourquoi.
"mange": Ok, c'est un chat en train
de manger, mais on ne sait pas quoi.
"goulûment": Ah, le chat à l'air de kiffer,
mais on sait toujours pas quoi.
"la" "souris": Ah, ben là finalement
on comprend!
Eh bien les réseaux récurrents permettent
en quelque sorte de mimer cette idée de:
Je lis progressivement et j'ai
une pensée en tête
qui se met à jour à chaque nouveau mot.
Un réseau récurrent est constitué
d'une brique élémentaire
qui prend en entrée une pensée
ainsi qu'un mot
et qui donne en sortie la pensée
modifiée par ce mot.
Et donc, pour analyser une phrase comme
"Le chat mange goulûment la souris",
eh bien on prend six copie du réseau
enchaînées
les unes à la suite des autres sur
chacun des mots de la phrase.
Là, vous allez me dire:
"c'est quoi une pensée? "
On a vu comment représenter un mot
par une suite de nombres,
avec un vecteur de dimension 300 par exemple,
mais une pensée, comment on va faire?
Eh ben, on va faire pareil, on va dire
qu'une pensée est aussi un vecteur,
une grande suite de nombres, on va juste
prendre une taille encore plus grande,
disons de dimension 1 000,
oui parce qu'une pensée c'est plus riche
qu'un simple mot,
donc il faudra bien 1 000 nombres réels
pour décrire un vecteur de pensée.
Ce vecteur, techniquement
on appelle ça plutôt:
"le vecteur d'état interne du réseau".
C'est un des chercheur du domaine,
Geoffrey Hinton,
qui avait proposé le terme
de "vecteur de pensée".
Je crois qu'il n'est pas tellement utilisé
dans les publications scientifiques,
mais je troue que ça colle assez bien
pour expliquer l'idée comme ça.
Par contre, comme pour les vecteurs
qui représentent les mots,
ces vecteurs de pensée sont des constructions
intermédiaires du réseau
qui n'ont aucun sens pour nous les humains,
ce sont des listes de nombres
qu'on ne sait pas interpréter.
C'est comme si la pensée était codée
par ce vecteur.
Bon, pour résumer:
une unité récurrente est donc comme
une petite machine
qui va prendre en entrée un vecteur
de pensée, souvent noté "h"
et un vecteur de mot "x" et donner
en sortie un nouveau vecteur de pensée.
Bien sûr, souvenez-vous qu'on parle
d'un réseau de neurones
donc dans le détail cette machine c'est
une fonction paramétrée par des poids
qu'on note toujours "W" et ce sont ces poids
qui seront réglés
durant la phase d'entraînement du réseau.
Bon, donc l'enchaînement d'unités récurrentes
sur les mots d'une phrase
permet donc de produire un vecteur
de pensée à partir de cette phrase
et comme le vecteur de pensée ressemble
à une version codée de la phrase
on appelle cet ensemble: un "encodeur".
Maintenant, ce qu'on va faire de ce qui sort
de l'encodeur
va dépendre du type de tâche
qu'on cherche à exécuter.
Prenons à nouveau notre problème simple
de la classification
des sentiments exprimés par une phrase,
la phrase: "Cette vidéo est loin d'être
aussi bonne que la précédente"
va être encodée sous la forme d'un vecteur
de pensée
et ce vecteur n'est pas interprétable
par un humain,
il faut donc ensuite le donner à
un autre réseau
dont le travail va être de classifier
la phrase
soit en positif soit en négatif par exemple.
Ce deuxième réseau ne sera pas
une unité récurrente,
ce sera une structure différente
qui prend en entrée un vecteur de pensée
et donne par exemple en sortie la probabilité
"y" que la phrase soit positive ou négative.
Bien entendu ce réseau va lui aussi posséder
ses poids "W" qu'il va falloir régler.
Le réglage des poids se fait conjointement
avec ceux du réseau récurrent
durant la phase d'apprentissage,
on va prendre des milliers de phrases
déjà classifiées à la main, on va les montrer
à notre réseau complet
et on va espérer qu'il apprenne à classifier
lui même les phrases.
Alors prenons maintenant la question
de la traduction, c'est plus compliqué
car en sortie on ne doit pas juste
donner un vecteur "y",
mais tout une suite de mot et
les deux phrases n'auront à priori
pas la même longueur dans les deux langues.
Par exemple une traduction du proverbe:
"All is fair in love and war"
ça pourrait être: "En amour comme à la guerre,
tous les coups sont permis",
7 mots d'un côté, 11 de l'autre, donc
on ne voudra surtout pas traduire mot à mot.
En fait on va faire l'inverse
de ce qu'on a fait pour encoder les phrases,
on va utiliser un réseau récurrent décodeur.
Je vous ai dit que le réseau encodeur
produisait à la fin
un vecteur de pensée sensé représenter
numériquement le sens de la phrase.
Eh bien maintenant, on va utiliser
une autre unité récurrente différente
qu'on va enchaîner pour produire
progressivement les mots de la traduction.
Cette unité-là prend en entrée
le vecteur de pensée
et produit en sortie un mot
dans l'autre langue ainsi
que le vecteur de pensée mis à jour,
et le vecteur de pensée va maintenant
en quelque sorte,
représenter l'état de ce
qu'il reste à traduire.
Par exemple en plein milieu de la traduction
de: All is fair in love and war"
il pourrait représenter le concept de:
"je dois encore traduire "all is fair",
mais pour "in love and war" c'est bon.
Évidemment on a toujours la même situation
qui est qu'avec un réseau de neurones,
ce qu'on aura en sortie, ce ne sont pas
des mots mais des nombres,
qu'il faudra interpréter comme
des probabilité d'avoir tel ou tel mot.
Et bien sûr, le réseau devra aussi être
capable de produire en sortie
un symbole qui dit: "stop, la traduction
est terminée".
Pour de la traduction on aura donc besoin
d'entraîner les deux réseaux récurrents,
l'encodeur et le décodeur, et ce
de façon conjointe
en leur présentant des phrases traduites
dans les deux langues.
On peux utiliser le même genre de technique
pour ce qui est un des problèmes
les plus spectaculaires des applications
du traitement du langage naturel:
la complétion de texte.
L'idée est simple, vous commencez
à écrire un texte
et vous laissez un algorithme le compléter
pour vous autant que vous voulez.
Le principe utilisé est un peu similaire
à celui de la traduction,
mais on demande cette fois
au réseau décodeur
de tenter de prédire le prochain mot,
il ne cherche pas à traduire la pensée,
mais à la compléter
de la façon qu'il estime la plus probable.
Malheureusement cette méthode du réseau
récurrent que je viens de vous décrire
si vous l'appliquez tel quel, ça ne va pas
forcément si bien fonctionner,
il y a une difficulté qui est
la gestion de la mémoire.
Imaginez la phrase:
Vous avez certainement deviné que le mot
qui vient après c'est: "anglais",
mais si je demande à un réseau récurrent
de compléter cette phrase,
il va falloir qu'il ait gardé
une bonne mémoire
du tout premier mot "Boston"
pour la compléter correctement
Or, quand on enchaîne les unités récurrentes
dans un encodeur,
le dernier mot aura bien plus d'impact
que le premier
sur le vecteur de pensée qui sort
de l'encodeur
et donc la mémoire des premiers mots
se trouvera d'autant plus diluée
que la phrase est longue.
Il existe plusieurs solutions techniques
pour essayer de limiter cet effet,
Par exemple: encoder une phrase
en la lisant dans les deux sens
ou bien conserver, en plus du vecteur d'état,
un autre vecteur de mémoire
qui se dilue moins, c'est le principe
des réseaux dits LFTM
pour "Long Short Term Memory",
mais il y a aussi les GRU pour
Gated Récurrent Unit".
Je ne vais pas détailler leur fonctionnement,
mais ils sont basés sur un certain nombre
de fonctions
qui cherchent à imiter ce qu'on pourrait
penser être
le fonctionnement de notre cerveau
comme la capacité à oublier ou retenir
sélectivement certaines informations
quand elles nous sont présentées.
Mais les progrès les plus significatifs
ont été obtenus avec ce qu'on appelle
le "mécanisme d'attention", qui permet
au réseau de se focaliser
sur certaines parties de la phrase d'entrée
pour produire sa sortie.
Une façon de le faire est de donner
au décodeur,
non pas juste le vecteur de pensée final,
mais tous les vecteurs de pensées
intermédiaires produits par l'encodeur,
avec des structures qui vont les traiter
pour en extraire des informations de contexte.
Mais la révolution la plus récente
dans le domaine date de 2017
où des chercheurs ont publié un article
scientifique intitulé:
"Attention is all you need",
dans cette publication, ils introduisent
une nouvelle structure de réseau
qui conserve le mécanisme d'attention,
mais se débarrasse des réseaux récurrents.
On donne cette fois toute la phrase
d'un coup
en encodant la position de chaque mot,
et le réseau va calculer l'attention
entre les différentes parties de la phrase.
Dans mon exemple avec Boston, le réseau
se rendrait par exemple compte
qu'il y a un lien entre les mots "Boston"
et "parler… anglais",
même si les mots sont très éloignés
dans la phrase.
La nouvelle architecture ainsi créée
s'appelle un "transformeur"
et les chercheurs d'OpenAI l'on utilisée
pour créer le modèle de langage GPT
qui en est actuellement à sa troisième
itération, GPT3.
Cette version a été entrainée sur des dizaines
de milliard de phrases en anglais
et il fallait bien ça parce que GPT3
posséderait
175 milliards de poids à ajuster
dans son réseau.
L'idée des transformeurs a énormément
inspiré les chercheurs du domaine
et c'est la même technique que l'on retrouve
derrière les modèles de langage BERT
développé par Google, mais aussi CamenBERT
un modèle en français
développé conjointement par Facebook
et l'INRIA.
Dans un autre genre, il y a quelque temps
dans une vidéo
je vous avais parlé du traitement
du problème du repliement des protéines,
eh bien on y retrouve aussi les transformeurs.
Sinon, petit rebondissement,
alors que j'étais en train de terminer
d'écrire cette vidéo,
un tout nouveau modèle de langage
en Français à été publié: Cédille.AI
et vous pouvez aller le tester librement
sur leur site,
notamment pour faire de la complétion
de texte,
ça fonctionne de façon très spectaculaire.
Évidemment, quand on voit tout ça on pense
au test de Turing
et on peut se demander si ces algorithmes
"comprennent" réellement ce qu'il racontent.
Ce qui ressort assez clairement c'est que
les réponses sont le plus souvent
vraiment plausibles, mais on voit que
l'algorithme manque souvent de cohérence,
il n'a pas de modèle mental du monde
qu'il décrit.
Ça se voit par exemple avec "AI Dungeon"
un algorithme basé sur GPT
qui vous propose de faire du jeu de rôle
en mode texte,
vous tapez ce que vous voulez et le maître
du jeu vous répond en complétant l'histoire
et c'est assez facile de faire des choses
incohérentes du genre:
"Je jette mon épée au fond du lac"
et ensuite, ben j'utilise mon épée à nouveau,
et le maître du jeu virtuel
n'y voit que du feu
alors qu'avec un vrai maître du jeu
ça ne passerait pas hein.
Mais pour des tâches relativement automatisées
comme la traduction,
les chatbox ou le fait de compléter
des textes simples,
eh bien ces algorithmes de complétion
de texte peuvent largement suffire.
Si vous faites de la programmation
je vous invite aussi à regarder
ce qui se fait en complétion de code,
c'est assez balaise.
Bien sûr, quand on les utilise
pour générer des textes,
tous ces modèles posent très vite
des questions
liées notamment aux biais des textes
qui ont été utilisés pour les entrainés.
Je ne vais pas vous montrer d'exemples,
mais on peut assez vite se rendre compte
du fait que ces modèles reproduisent
sans surprise les biais racistes ou sexistes
qu'on trouve dans les textes qui ont servi
à leur construction
Il faudrait pas mal de temps
pour en parler bien,
donc je vous renvoie sur la chaîne
"Science for all"
où Lê aborde souvent cette question.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
pour ceux qui veulent creuser,
plus de détails sont disponible dans
le billet de blog, comme toujours.
Partagez la vidéo, histoire d'en faire
profiter tout le monde, abonnez-vous,
mettez des pouces et des cloches en offrande
à l'algorithme de Youtube
et on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéo, à bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -